[Music]
President Trump is about to speak in
Fargo North Dakota will go to the event
as soon as it begins good evening and
welcome to our Carlson tonight it was a
drama packed news day-to-day courtesy of
Supreme Court Justice Anthony Kennedy
Kennedy announced his retirement for
Supreme Court this afternoon that gives
the president the chance to appoint his
second justice that could result in a
big change to the courts ideological
makeup as well as quite an ideological
battle Kennedy was routinely the swing
vote on the most contentious cases
before the court she hadn't bream hosts
Fox News at night of course she's also
our judiciary correspondent and an
accomplished attorney and she joins us
tonight with an overview of what this
means hey now hey Tucker well you know
Justice Kennedy gave us the ultimate
head-fake this morning they had gaveled
the term done they said we'll see you
back here on the bench in October and we
didn't get an announcement so we let our
guard down just a little bit then
suddenly just before 2 p.m. Eastern it
felt like a shock wave Kennedy really is
letting the president know he's gonna
step down he wanted to go talk to the
president folks at the White House told
me it felt like a top secret mission
getting him in and out without being
seen which obviously would have set all
of us into the rumor mill overdrive
Kennedy's letter to the president was
very simple talking about the highest
honor it was to serve on the court
calling it a quote privilege to seek in
each case how best to know interpret and
defend the Constitution and the laws
that must always conform to its mandates
and promises now though Kennedy was
reliably conservative on a number of
issues he was definitely left-of-centre
on issues like abortion and LGBT rights
well tonight the left is in full
meltdown mode in some corners vowing to
block any Senate moves to try to fill
Kennedy seat before the midterms here is
the Senate's top Democrat Chuck Schumer
Americans should make it clear that they
will not tolerate a nominee chosen from
president Trump's preordained list
selected by powerful special interests
who will reverse the progress we have
made over the decades
senator unlikely 2020 presidential
hopeful Kamala Harris says this quote we
should not vote on confirmation until
they voted at the bow
box the president's list of potential
nominees are complete non starters they
are conservative ideologues instead of
mainstream jurists we cannot and will
not accept them to serve on the highest
court in the land
which is supposed to stand for equal
protection under the law and justice for
all not really sure how that's gonna
work since the Republicans do control
the Senate by the way I've got one of
the shortlist errs joining me tonight at
11:00 p.m. Senator Michael Lee I'm gonna
ask him how he feels about being called
a non-starter and a complete
conservative ideologue Tucker we'll see
what he says will be interesting to see
how Democrats plan to stop that shannon
bream will be covering this of course
every day until it happens good to see
it